I'm putting on the Callaway corner this
is the way to get ready for Bubba Watson
if only he could see me right now he
could maybe give me a tip I mean he can
hear you know is he called in already
yeah he's always on the phone you want
to put him through
um I mean this would be an odd way to
meet what okay
hey do you want to Bob are you there
it's rich eyes and we're live yeah I'm
here man
how are you I'm we're about to come back
from break and do this on the radio
television simulcast right now I'm
putting on our putting surface here do
you have any and we've never talked you
don't even know my game
is there any like overall overarching
tip for putting you could give me I
would try what I would try to do first
thing I would do is try to put a little
bit more weight on your front foot your
lead foot okay and I would do that just
kind of lean into it a little bit helps
you kind of stay down on the putt a
little bit so you don't come out up and
out of it Bubba I just made the putt
literally leaning on my front foot this
is a beautiful relationship let's try
one more time here Bob Watson you're on
the Rich Eisen show how are you Bubba
I'm great man thanks for having me
yeah of course so you're in my old
stomping ground Central Connecticut
right now I assume correct yeah I'm
right here at the TPC River Highlands
now there's a few divots right there and
I'm wondering if you could let me know
they're right they're right further back
than where your divots would be in 17 in
particular and there's a few golf balls
in the water around there if you find
them they're mind Bubba okay yeah okay
so keep an eye peeled on that if you
don't mind I will I'll give my my what
does that really call it my ball get her
out of there
I love it you don't need to know you hit
one in the lobby oh my god I get ball I
get golf balls for free so I don't even
don't even faze me you know I betcha
that's fantastic but this this this spot
is a special spot for you and I'd love
for you to give you the floor as to why
you you love playing in this tournament
Bubba you know it's one of those things
where when travelers took over they took
over the right way they they asked not
just what we want or what we like and
what the caddies like they asked what
our families like that's what the fans
like but then on top of that in 2010 my
dad was about to pass away of a throat
cancer and I my first win on tour 2010
my dad got to witness it got my family
got to take a break for a little bit you
know of this tragic thing that's about
to happen and my dad it was about three
months after that when he passed away
and so it's for me it's that little
thing that means so much to my family
meant so much to my dad meant so much to
me being able to say I won one time with
my dad getting to see me so so
Connecticut Hartford Cromwell disc golf
course this sponsor it means so much to
me and my family you know it's beyond
golf right it's one of those things
where when I come here it's it's like
I'm walking my dad again mmm that's
amazing and you've won the event three
times what about the course itself it
sets up for you Bubba
you think I think it's like I said I
think it's one of the things that's just
peaceful for me but the golf course is
you know for me the way the whole shape
the way the length of the golf course
there's a lot of things that favor my
game and even when I don't win I haven't
had a chance I finished second one time
how the another couple top-10 finishes
but it's just the way the Golf Course
sets up I mean if I hit driver well I'm
gonna have a lot of short irons even
into the par fives so it's a chance for
me to make a lot of birdies and that's
what helps me Bubba Watson two-time
Masters champion here
on the Rich Eisen show and here you are
now here we are as fans of the sport mid
June and three majors are already in the
books and it's the first time where
we've got a new reconfigured schedule
where April's masters may is PGA
Championship US Open Championship
obviously just last week Open
Championship next month FedEx Cup
towards the FedEx Series is later on
well do you like this so do the players
like this schedule Bubba yeah we do we
love it the reason why is because we all
want to watch football too you know we
don't want to be placed on that we want
we want to see the college and then we
want to see pros so it's one of those
things where it gives us options instead
of having to not having to but but
instead of playing all year round or a
longer schedule we have the option of
stopping your finish in August or end of
August so you can you can stop or if you
want to play the fall series when you
get bored at the house you can go back
out and play really favors guys that
want to travel or want to spend time
with their kids so that's the beauty of
it now you still have the option to play
in nobody's making us play tournaments
and so that's what we love about it we
can we can just pick and choose and or
take a long time off if we want well I
love the this I love this new setup I
love that there's a major once a month
for four straight months and then as you
said once August hits there's kind of a
new fall season that would pair with an
NFL season in a way I guess you know I I
I kind of dig it Bubba as a fan I really
enjoy it yeah yeah I mean and then
obviously you can't I mean Jay Monaghan
and the PGA Tour's look like geniuses
especially with Tiger win in the first
one you know that makes everybody
interested in watching the other ones
you know but um yeah the way they're
doing it like you know it's it's spaced
out just enough where it's still a great
tournament every month now every
tournament is great but the majors are
right after each other makes it happen
faster so the fans are still energized
from the last one when the next one
comes so Bubba Watson here on the Rich
Eisen show a few minutes left with him
so you're one of only 17 people to walk
planet to have won the Masters more than
one so you're one of the few people who
can answer this question do you get the
same jacket when you win at a second
time yes it's the same one yeah so I
have the same one that I had before so
you get a ding Jack Nicola I mean Jack
Nicholas would have what six of them you
know yeah I mean it's a lot of yarn
maybe weights and so on you know what if
you've put on a few lbs you know what I
mean well they they you know Augusta
comes up with a lot of people real fast
and there's a tailor that could be on
staff obviously they don't want to let
you know what might be going behind the
scenes but I'm just one tour in with
with the seams of the jacket so that's
what I'm wondering if if you get the
same one on it's it the first time that
you've put it when you won the second
one was it the first time you would put
that jacket on since you had won the
first one no you you know you have it
for Champions dinner on Tuesday nights
you wear it and then if you go in like
say if I come in like three weeks before
the tournament and I stay overnight
mm-hmm
any time I eat dinner there I wear it it
won't pretty much anytime they let me
have a chance like when Tiger won I wore
my jacket down there I can graduate him
right I was gonna wear it any chance
they give me I'm gonna wear it okay like
I'd sleep in it I don't even know if
they would let you do that right mind so
my jacket my jacket is pretty big and I
actually asked if I get a tailor in NEX
time to look at it but um the first one
they put on me in twelve I was like this
is perfect they said it's a little big I
said no it's great don't take it off I
bet so I just stayed with that one what
what what did you think about Tiger
winning Bubba no it's amazing for
athletes in general it's amazing for the
game of golf young people you know in 97
when he won his first when he
fist-pumped on the last hole after
winning in 97 I mean I was graduating
high school and so I mean I just
inspired me and so now being able to see
that kids that are born after that right
now get to see him and hear about the
stories and now get to witness it so
it's like right now I you know I only
know from stories from Arnold Palmer
Jack Nicklaus
but now I've got the C Tiger when I
wasn't a pro and then when I am a pro to
witness it and this is a greatest
comeback story out of any sport that I
could think of you know by far and then
there's this story of Gary woodland this
weekend I don't know if you're friendly
with them or obviously playing the same
tours and we were your thoughts on him
winning his first at Pebble the way he
did no unbelievable we always joke
because my true name is uh my real name
is Gary okay but it spelled it spelled
different than his so every time in the
locker room he's like hey Gary I'm like
hey Gary and and so that's our little
joke but yeah I mean watching him win
the way he does it the way he goes about
it like I mean it's almost like him and
Brooks kept I like the way they know
emotion and kind of obviously when you
chip in you get emotional but like you
know you just try to be stoic and go
through the round so what a battle that
was but yeah for him he's such a great
guy
pretty special to watch him win like
that last one for you but before I let
you go I would love to talk a little
football with you since you said you'd
like to watch some football on the
weekends what's your professional what's
your NFL team and your college team
Bubba well I mean college I've got to go
with Georgia sand versus me and my wife
went there but um I'm a huge fan of when
I meet people um so I pull for certain
teams because of people I've met or play
golf with and I'm a Tom Brady on a big
shoe I mean anybody that keeps doing
that year after year is pretty special I
played golf with his dad but I haven't
played golf for him but um Bill
Belichick good you know become friends
with him
very interesting to learn from him and
talk to him Sean Payton down at UM New
Orleans Saints so I'm all over the map
but I mean it was awesome to see Boston
pull it out and do the things they've
been able to do well Tom senior you want
to talk about Brady's dad he's in aces
individual he's like a great human on
planet Earth oh my gosh I play you know
what it would play pebble play Pebble
Beach with him back in a years ago and I
saw Tom Brady senior and I was like
there's no way this is dad and they
exact yeah dad hey hey hey so it was it
was pretty cool but yet down-to-earth I
mean what what a what a great family man
and
and everything so yeah it's been cool
getting to know that family a little bit
all right and who's the best NFL player
you've teed it up with who's the best
and who's the best at golf out of any
NFL player oh man that's a great
question
kickers are usually better because they
have more time they don't get hit as
much you know you know but but Larry
Fitzgerald man what a grinder that guys
up hitting more he's hit more range
balls and his lifetime now that I've
ever hit in my lifetime and I'm a
professional golfer so it's pretty
amazing his work ethic okay that he puts
into it and everything so I mean he's
not the best but gosh is his drive to
become better it's pretty special that's
why he's Fitz that's why he's lying
I enjoyed the the chat and for our radio
audience during the TV segment you
popped on and gave me a couple tips
about leaning on my front foot putting
weight on my front foot when putting and
I drained two putts so I feel better not
just as a host but as a player for
having you on this program exactly exact
time here for thanks for coming on Bubba
a good lesson I hope to have you on
again soon thanks for calling that's
Bubba Watson at Bubba Watson on Twitter
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app